hi welcome to this video on time
traveling simulators using blockchains
and their applications
i'm pratik soni from carnegie mellon
university and this is joint work with
whipple coil and justin raises
so in this work we introduce a new way
to capture security a for cryptographic
systems using blockchains
so blockchain is an emerging new
technology where a set of computers
distributed over the internet they come
together to maintain a global public
ledger
and this ledger provides several
interesting properties for example it's
an up and only letter so data can only
be added to the ledger but not removed
anybody on the internet can add data to
this ledger
anybody with an internet access can
get the latest state of the blockchain
most importantly all honest parties have
the same view of the ledger
the central application of blockchains
has been to get decentralized
cryptocurrencies like ethereum and
bitcoin
which today have a combined market value
of 1 trillion us dollars
but now blockchains have infiltrated
many different areas and have several
different applications
blockchains have often been viewed as a
consumer of cryptography and in fact
designing cryptography for blockchains
is a rapidly advancing and a well
motivated research direction
but recently blockchains are also being
viewed as an enabler for cryptography
and there are several interesting
properties of blockchains that make them
suitable for building cryptography
for example the work of gold and goyal
use blockchains as an alternative to
trusted setups to build non-interactive
zero knowledge
a sequence of works use blockchains to
achieve fairness in multiparty
computation
and quite interestingly blockchains
enable encrypting to the future you via
this notion of time log encryption
in this work we want to take this
direction even further and ask a meta
level question
specifically we ask whether blockchains
can enable us to capture new interesting
security properties
we here seek for a new security
definition
but how do we prove security in
cryptography to begin with
so a common goal
in cryptography is to quantify the
knowledge and adversary learns when it's
interacting with the crypto system
so consider the example in the slide
where an adversary is interacting with
alice
she's and she's in possession of some
secret and the adversary is actively
trying to learn some information about
the secret
for security we would like to show that
the adversary learns no information
about the secret from this interaction
this is typically argued by showing the
existence of a simulator
who can simulate the adversary's
interaction with alice
without having access to alice's secret
and this intuitively implies that the
adversary learns no non-trivial
information about the secret
this simulation paradigm is central to
proving security of a number of crypto
systems including encryption schemes
zero knowledge proofs multiparty
computation program obfuscation
so simulation paradigm is prevalent
throughout cryptography
ideally we would like to ha uh have
simulator and verif and uh the adversary
have the same powers
but for feasibility simulator is often
given extra power over the adversary and
this extra power over the adversary
manifests itself in many different ways
for example the simulator is allowed to
refine the adversary
is allowed
sometimes given access to the code of
the adversary or even allowed to run in
time significantly larger than the
adversary and all of these different
powers give rise to different security
notions
in this work we give
a new power to the simulator
the power of time travel
we give the simulator a peek into the
future
specifically we give him a future we
give the simulator a future blockchain
state
we refer to such a simulator as a time
traveling simulator and the
corresponding notion as time travel
simulation
the primary contribution of our work is
to rigorously define this notion of time
traveling simulation using the idea of
blockchains
and hopefully as we we will see later in
the talk that time travelling simulation
is non-trivial gives interesting
security gravities and is often times
easier to work with
additionally we also investigate the
power of time travelling simulation in
the context of two fundamental
cryptographic tasks
of zero knowledge proofs and security
party computation
specifically in each of these situations
we give a three-round protocol
specifically we give a three-round
protocol for zero knowledge
uh where the zero knowledge is defined
with respect to a time travelling black
box simulator
we also show a three round secure
two-party competition where we get time
traveling simulation security against
both parties
these three round protocols highlight
the usefulness of our new notion
specifically three-round protocols with
standard simulation were either
impossible or required novel assumptions
in the context of zero knowledge
whereas no construction for three-round
two-party computation was known prior to
our work for polynomial time simulation
so in the rest of the talk is divided
into four parts in the first part i want
to give you a quick overview of
blockchains and this will set us up
nicely to define our new notion of time
travelling simulation in the context of
zero knowledge for interactive proofs
then we will state our results a bit
more formally
and finally in part four
i'll briefly describe our three round
zero knowledge construction which will
hopefully give you a taste of how time
travelling simulation is used
so blockchains
so in blockchains there are users who
want to post data and then there are a
set of miners who are running a
distributed consensus protocol to
maintain the ledger
specifically users who want to post some
data they send it to this network of
miners
whereupon one of these miners is chosen
as the leader according to the rules of
the underlying consensus protocol
and then this leader gets to append this
data
in the form of blocks
to the ledger
and blockchain continuously grow users
can post more data
a new leader is elected and new blocks
get added
to the chain
a little bit more detail these blocks
not only contain data but also contain a
pointer to the previous block
and this is what results in the
formation of a block chain
and these pointers are particularly
useful because they enable us to check
whether two blocks are adjacent or not
specifically there is this is valid
predicate which can um which uh
checks returns one if you give him give
this valid predicate to adjacent blocks
specifically
the isvalid predicate on blocks a and b
is going to return 1 but on a and c is
going to return 0.
and this is particularly useful when
someone
with the candidate block d
can check whether it's a valid extension
of the current blockchain state c or not
but how are new blocks getting generated
recall leader is the one who gets to add
new blocks to the chain
so miners are continuously engaged in a
puzzle solving race
where they are solving moderately hard
puzzles
and the the winner of this race becomes
the leader
the puzzle-solving race is simulated in
many different ways but the key idea is
to ensure that the probability of
getting elected as a leader
is proportional to the resources that
the miner devotes to the system
the earliest of the blockchains like
bitcoin were based on a proof-of-work um
based mechanism where miners are
continually devoting their cpu cycles to
solve some puzzles
and the probability of getting selected
as the leader is proportional to their
computing power
but now several other interesting
proposals are in place like proof of
stake proof of space proof of space time
and so on
the key idea behind all of these
proposals is just to prevent
the notorious civil attacks
which are well known in the literature
a main
assumption underlying all of these
blockchains
is the honest majority assumption where
uh
irrespective of how which of these
resources are used or which of these
mechanisms are used as the puzzle
solving race uh we want to ensure that
the adversary does not control more than
uh 50 of the computing power
and this is uh
referred to as the honest majority
assumption and it this is what enables
uh interesting properties like consensus
and this is also going to be relevant
for us later in the talk
okay
so now now that we have defined now that
we have described what blockchains are
let me now define
this notion of time traveling simulation
for zero knowledge
okay so what are interactive proofs
interactive through soft protocol an
interactive protocol between two parties
prover in the verifier where the
approver is trying to prove to the
verifier that a certain statement x
uh is uh true
and uh we want standard properties like
completeness which says that uh if the
statement is indeed true or it belongs
to this language then the honest prover
can convince the verifier
uh we also want soundness uh
which says that if the statement is
indeed false then no cheating prover
should be able to convince the verifier
to accept
the most relevant security property for
today's talk is zero knowledge which
provides privacy guarantees against a
cheating verifier
specifically we say an interactive proof
system is zero knowledge if the cheating
verifier
learns no information about the prover's
witness from the interaction
recall from the interaction that this is
argued by showing the existence of a
simulator that can simulate the view of
the verifier with the prover without
knowing the prover's witness
and this is a seminal notion uh
introduced in um in the work of gold
wasser mekali and rakoff in 89
and they require the simulator to uh
they require the simulator to run in uh
polynomial time
so the really the philosophy and we
refer to this notion uh introduced by
gmr as the standard notion of zero
knowledge
and really the philosophy behind the
standard notion of zero knowledge is
that whatever the verifier learns
from interacting with approval it could
have computed on its own by running the
simulator which runs in polynomial time
and there are new there have been
numerous other formulations since the
seminal work uh of goldwater mikali and
rakhov uh that capture different
philosophies
for example uh
there's this notion called zero
knowledge in the crs model where uh
which enables the following guarantee uh
that whatever the verifier learns from
the proof it could have computed on its
known if it had access to the trap doors
inside the crs and since
and here the simulator is given access
or rather the ability to sample the crs
trapdoor
so in this work we want we we focus on
achieving a a very different philosophy
right so we want to achieve that
whatever the verifier learns from the
proof
it could have computed on its own
shortly into the future
and to capture this we have to give
simulator the ability to look into the
future
and we call the resulting notion as time
travelling zero knowledge
and really the question is how do we
formalize this because this requires a
notion of time
right
and this is where blockchains are
particularly useful because they give us
a natural notion of time for example the
blocks being continuously
added can be used as a parameter for
keeping track of time
so before i can define uh the time
travelling simulation uh formally uh
we'll have to adapt our protocol uh to
to the presence of blockchain for
example the current state of the
blockchain is now going to be given as
common input to all parties including
the prover the verifier the adversary
and as well as the simulator
additionally the simulator will be given
a
an extra
input which is an f block valid
extension
uh
of the current state of the blockchain
and as we will see later in the talk
that this is uh particularly useful
because such an f block extension uh
cannot be computed by uh by a by an
adversary that controls only minority
computing power and this is what would
allow us uh to show soundness of our
proof systems but for now let's go back
uh to define uh to formally define this
notion of time traveling zero knowledge
so recall now that
all parties are given
st which is the current state of the
blockchain in addition to their regular
inputs
and additionally simulator is now given
this additional input of b1 through bf
which is an f block valid extension of
the current state of the blockchain
right
and we call a proof system uh to satisfy
uh f time travelling uh zero knowledge
if there is a simulator uh that works
for all cheating verifiers uh by works
we mean that they are able to simulate
the view of all verifiers
now i've given you this new notion you
need to ask me how interesting or how
good is this time traveling simulation
right
really at the very core what it tries to
capture is that the only information
that the verifier learns from
interacting with the prover
today
it would have anyways learned uh
tomorrow for example after f blocks are
being added
and this already seems a little bit
weaker than the standard notion of zero
knowledge and technically it is
but really the differences depend on the
statement that you're proving
uh to substantiate my point let's
consider a couple of examples so for
example if you are using a proof system
to uh zero knowledge proof system to
prove statements of the form
where the statement is a commitment uh
to uh honest party's input and
randomness and the witness is the honest
party's input and randomness then really
the time traveling notion of knowledge
gives essentially the same guarantees as
the standard notion of zero knowledge
this is because passage of time or
adding more blocks to the blockchain
is not going to magically break the
security of the commitment schemes
so really uh the only information that
the verifier would learn
uh from the addition of new blocks to
the blockchain would be independent of
of
the corresponding statement uh that
we're proving
having said that uh really if you're but
but if you're using uh uh time traveling
simulation proof systems for
uh proving statements of the form uh
which is which includes a time lock
puzzle whose solution is inherently
going to be let's say for example league
tomorrow
then uh the time traveling simulation
zero knowledge proof systems would end
up living uh leaking uh the solution
today itself
so in this sense it's uh it's weaker
than the no standard notion of zero
knowledge
also we are not the first one to give
additional powers to the simulator uh
for example there is this uh
uh well studied line of work which
which is called a super polynomial
simulation wherein uh the simulation the
simulator is given access to a super
powerful oracle or an angel that breaks
for example uh commitments of certain uh
security of certain commitment schemes
uh although this is very imp uh
as a notion it's very impactful and
allows us to circumvent numerous
impossibility results uh uh really uh
there's a big drawback of this uh notion
is that it's very hard to argue the
security of the honest parties in the
presence of uh
such a powerful angel
so in summary uh uh this this uh this
provider this uh this results in more
complicated proofs uh for super
polynomial time simulation
traveling simulation can also be viewed
as an uh super polynomial time
simulation where the angel is
a specific uh uh
provides a specific functionality uh
specifically it gives a future it
computes the future blockchain states
and uh provides them instantaneously to
you
however an advantage in our scheme is
that really the the security that the
angel breaks is not that it's breaking a
commitment scheme but rather
something that would automatically be
broken in the future
right so uh so this gives us uh this
tells us that the time traveling
simulation zero knowledge is certainly
stronger than uh super polynomial
simulation and it's easier to understand
and uh and and
results in simpler proofs uh uh simpler
security proofs
so zero knowledge assimilation has also
been considered previously in in the
blockchain model for example there is a
line of work by uh uh
chaudhary goel and jane where they
introduced this new notion of standard
simulation
uh in the context of uh
in the presence of blockchain
however this notion was shown to be
impossible for constant land protocols
comparatively uh our notion is actually
as we show is a need possible for to
achieve for three round protocols
uh and arguably with a very simple
construction hopefully uh that we will
see at the end of the talk
uh i also want to mention another notion
called the majority notion considered by
the work of girl and goyal uh
in fact this is possible to achieve also
for non-interactive protocols but here
the simulator is given a lot of power
specifically it controls all honest
parties
in the
in the blockchain network uh for example
this can allow the uh simulator to pass
the blockchain and even rewind and
delete uh
uh blocks from the blockchain right
uh comparatively uh in in the notion in
the time traveling uh simulation setting
the simulator only controls one party
and having access to for example having
access to this future state doesn't let
uh the simulator go back and rewind the
blockchain for example
okay
so hopefully uh by this point uh you're
familiar with the notion of time
travelling simulation zero knowledge and
see how it compares to uh many different
uh uh
uh many different notions proposed in
the literature and now this is already
this is set up us set us up to uh to say
our results a bit more formally
so uh the first theorem that we show is
that we assuming the existence of
injective memory functions we show that
there is a three round
zero knowledge argument where the zero
knowledge is with respect to a strict
polynomial time black box time traveling
simulator
and uh comparatively uh uh achieving the
same task using standard simulation uh
uh is is known to be impossible for
black box simulation and for non-black
box simulation even though constructions
are known they require normal
cryptographic assumptions
so i want to say a little bit more that
um like the the zero knowledge aspect of
our construction uh follows directly
from uh uh from one way functions
uh
soundness however requires uh uh making
new uh new but natural assumptions on
the underlying mining puzzles although
theorem does not say uh say this
explicitly uh very uh at a very
intuitive level uh what we want is that
uh let's say a group of minors uh and uh
the adversary who controls uh minority
computational power they start uh
creating blocks uh uh
they start creating extensions from a
specific block let's say a then uh the
adversary cannot uh outpace uh the
honest minors and this seems a very
natural assumption to make
however in the in the paper we we need
we need more natural strengthenings of
this assumption for for uh for our
constructions
i also want to quickly mention about our
two-party secure computation results so
two body computation uh
is a protocol between two parties let's
say alice and bob who have their private
inputs x and y and they want to jointly
compute uh uh uh the function uh let's
some function
f uh
here we want the correctness guarantee
that the receiver which is basically
this party uh always gets uh um
the output f of x comma y and in terms
of simulation uh security is defined via
the notion of a simulation wherein we
want to capture that receive each of the
parties do not learn anything about the
other party's input
right
although i've not defined explicitly but
time travelling simulation can also be
extended to the setting of two-party
computation which we defined in the
paper
uh
uh we we actually give you uh
our theorem more completely
is assuming the extension
existence of injective one-way functions
and public key encryption and signatures
and two-round oblivious transfer we
build a three-round two-party secure
competition protocol wherein we achieve
simulation security against both parties
and the simulation security is with
respect to a time traveling simulator
so a prior work on uh on time try on uh
prior work uh on on building three round
uh two party competition protocols uh
for standard simulation was only known
for a weaker class of adversaries
okay so in the final part final few
minutes i want to give you a taste of
how
a taste of the construction of our three
round zero knowledge uh protocol
so um our three round construction
follows the phi gay shamir lapidad
paradigm where the prover is given
the approval and the verifier given a
common blockchain state st
and also the approver now wants to prove
to the verifier that x is in the
language
to do so uh the prover actually gives
out a witness and distinguishable proof
showing it either knows a witness for x
or no some chapter and this trapped our
information in our case is going to be a
f block ballot extension of the current
blockchain state
note that the honest proverb can
actually produce a proof for the witness
and distinguishable proof using uh the
real witness w
the simulator uh is quite
straightforward uh the sumerian is given
access to an f block extension and hence
can compute
the witness and distinguishable proof in
accepting witness and distinguishable
proof using the second branch
in the language
and by witnessing distinguishability of
the underlying proof system it's uh it's
straightforward to see that the
simulator does a good job in simulating
the view of the verifier
so really uh the construction is simple
the time traveling zero knowledge
security guarantee is pretty much
straightforward
but really soundness is where we have to
start working a bit harder specifically
we want to show that no cheating prover
can convince the verifier on some
statement x that is not in the language
intuitively we want to argue that uh for
such statements not in the language uh
it's not possible for the proverb to use
the trapdoor branch or the branch b2 or
for the witness indistinguishable proof
system
but there's an issue here the adversary
could actually just wait for until uh f
blocks are added to the current state of
the blockchain and this allows uh the
the uh the the approval to to get the
witness uh to prove the trapdoor branch
right
so to resolve this we have to implement
a timeout parameter timeout mechanism
let's say we introduce a primary
parameter k which is much much less than
f and the verifier is uh
starts rejecting uh proofs from the
prover if indeed it takes a long time
for the proverb to produce the proof
and of course we have to reset k
appropriately so that the honest prover
doesn't actually time out
okay
so uh really now to show soundness we
want to leverage the fact that the
underlying witness and distinguishable
proof system has a special property
called special soundness
specifically for every input for every
string x
if
if the adversary gives out let's say two
uh witness and distinguishable proofs
accepting proofs where the first
statement where the first message
remains the same
then the uh the the witness and
distinguished proofs special soundness
property uh provides a way to extract a
witness w prime which is either a
witness for the language uh for x or an
a violet x f block extension
and this also holds for uh x not in the
language and in that case
uh the special soundness of the
underlying wi system provides us a way
to extract an f block extension
and this is going to be the key idea
behind behind the soundness proof
specifically we want to use the cheating
prover that convinces that gives
convincing proofs for false statements
and extract a valid f block extension
from such an adversary
but the challenge here is that uh the
the the honest prover or sorry the
cheating prover ends up interacting with
the blockchain this means that the
blockchain adversary that we are trying
to build needs to be able to simulate
the blockchain uh in each of these
threads thread one and thread prime one
prime for the adversary
the way we solve this is by uh allowing
the adversary enough power to compute
short forks
uh at a very very high level this is how
the reduction or how we would build the
blockchain adversary so the blockchain
anniversary let's say is given the
current state of the blockchain st it
internally runs the cheating prover
waits for it to reply with the first
message w1 and let's say the
blockchain has expanded its state to st1
by that time
at this point uh the simulator uh the
blockchain adversary internally creates
a a fork of the current blockchain state
denoted by orange in the slides
and continues the execution of thread
one and thread one prime with the
adversary note that in thread one it is
still interacting with the
uh the the global blockchain but in
thread one prime it's interacting with
uh the local blockchain that the
blockchain adversaries internally
internally trying to compute and most
importantly you know that uh since the
cheating approver will timeout within uh
within k blocks are being added the
blockchain adversary only needs to
create a small fork of k blocks
internally and now given two transcripts
thread one and thread prime we should be
able to extract an f block extension of
the current blockchain state
and this clearly violates uh or
implicitly violates
an assumption on the plot
on the hardness of the mining procedure
uh at a very informal level what we
really want is that uh an adversary was
given an ability to uh create a fork of
uh k blocks at maybe the rate uh
proportional to that of the honest
minors is somehow magically cannot
produce a chain of f blocks where f is
substantially larger than k
this is a very informal description of
the assumption that we need a for more
formal version we outlined in the paper
okay finally towards conclusion
uh
so in this work we introduced this new
notion of zero knowledge uh simulator
sorry a new notion of simulator called
time traveling
simulator we define this rigorously
using blockchains and we also
investigate the power of these time
traveling simulators in the context of
zero knowledge and secure to pc
okay so um
i i couldn't cover a lot of details and
i invite you to look at the paper uh but
at a very high level uh we have to work
harder uh
to to adapt to uh blockchain's weak
consensus uh note that today we
implicitly assume that all honest
parties
agree on the current blockchain state
but rather
blockchain provide you only with a
weaker guarantee
that all honest parties agree on all but
the final few blocks
so adapting to this week consensus
requires a bit of work
uh
in the context of our zero knowledge
protocol what the property that turns
out to be more useful is a strengthening
of the soundness called argument of
knowledge
which we didn't discuss today so in the
paper we have to uh we have to
formulate a new notion of argument of
knowledge uh with respect to a time
travelling knowledge extractor
uh
for our three round two pc result uh the
key component uh is extracting is a way
to extract adversaries inputs for this
we have to come up with a new two round
protocol uh for an extractable
commitment scheme uh where the extractor
also is a time traveling extractor
and finally our current techniques only
work with proof of work-based
blockchains
would be interesting to extend this to
other
other
blockchains
specifically the issue is that for our
constructions we still require that
having an adversary that has access to
all the secret keys of the honest miners
can still not uh outpace the honest
miners in computing uh in computing
blocks and this is true for
proof-of-work-based blockchains but
certainly not true for proof-of-stake
based blockchains so there's a lot more
interesting questions
arising out of this work that i hope you
guys uh look at and solve
so thank you for listening the paper is
on eprint
thanks again